all right let's go hopefully everything
is set to go
for one final youtube 2020.
all right i think
i think everything is good so today well
tonight
i really wanted to show you one of my
favorite games that i played
um so this was back in 2015 memorial
i have shown the other games from this
tournament
but um i really wanted to talk about
this one because
uh last time we talked a little bit
about some lopez ideas
and i so wanted to um kind of mix it up
a little
showed my experience with this line and
i especially liked it because well he
was
higher rated by 200 something
and this was one of the first
tournaments that
i didn't make my iam norm
so i had like a bunch of these
tournaments that i played that was so
close i would get wg mom but i would not
get an iem norm
and that it was just so frustrating so
anybody who is hunting norm or
has recently finished haunting norms
have
probably felt what i felt it was just
yes so hopefully this won't be the
timeline
for this video so i really
enjoyed this game specifically because i
um prepared for it so i kind of knew
what i what i was doing a little bit
before the game
but i really enjoyed it because the game
had overall
turned out to be very great um
and i bluffed on it on little so it was
really good
um i'm gonna go ahead and get started
because it's a very long game and i
would
hate for it's not to finish all right
um so against roy lopez those of you who
have been around and
know me know that i do generally weird
stuff with g6 and d6
and id7 and i rarely do a6
so um i got
this a6 and after i got my a6 this was
like
this was my preparation because i knew
that my opponent
plays this closed line and my biggest
question was
so if he's going to play d3 and if he
does not usually play this d4 lines
either with c3 or if he doesn't intend
to do d4
anytime early on then why am i why can't
i just go for the same thing and just
throw a g6 a little later on
and so that is what i did i went for
this after d3
d6 c3 and i did my g6
um so this is not very common but
it was one of my biggest question that
if you are not going to
um play d4 then g6 is going to work out
so why shouldn't i do it
and so i did so for those of you who
also experienced this g6 and have these
type of questions about
transpositions feel free to question it
because
even if the opening line this is not the
first choice or the second choice or the
third choice
uh if this idea is not that it doesn't
mean that it's not a good idea it just
means you got to be creative
uh i manny well you i mean i
i got my first norm and i crossed 2400
in austria bundesliga was great actually
and i also kind of got drunk after that
i was already 18. it was europe it was
great
and then um i got my second one
no sorry first and second one up to you
in this in the same month
yeah and then third one i got it over
the summer
um so talking about g5
well bishop g5s are always kind of
possible
but uh it doesn't really do much because
i always have this h6 you can go
to e3 but i'm gonna do this bishop g7
anyways
so it doesn't really do
much to be honest
so in the game my opponent castle then
yes he could have tried for d4s but also
leaves e4 wonderable
and this is like the this is very
similar to
this uh starting with g6 let me go back
starting with g6 uh let's say you play
c3
and say your castle i kick you oops
that's not the right way
i kick you away and then
this is a similar position but one time
be less because now i would have knight
f6 and it would be black to move again
um if you were to play like d4 because
you play the d3 and then at d4 it kind
of wastes a time
i played austria bundesliga in 2016
february i think it was yeah
i was playing for them 2015-16 i was
also applying for
the uh switzerland in bundesliga our
team actually won
very proud i was i was seriously
concerned moving to central land but
somehow i
still had my heart set for us because i
already speak the language
but yeah i wouldn't mind living in
switzerland
very green less headaches but
well anyways uh that's a whole different
conversation
so g6 um my opponent
played this castle and bishop g7 rookie
one
and i went for normal stuff with castle
and um oh gmp she just woke up
nope never mind just change position
okay it's actually very cute um 92 now
my question to you so you guys kind of
are somewhat very uh briefly familiar
with the ideas that
are in this uh line so what do you think
what do you think white wants to do what
do you think black wants to do
i'll give you a little hint why it's uh
generally
in lopez white wants to do this cool
idea of going to f5
but since we already have g6 that's kind
of non-existent
anymore so what do you think
johnny i saw that's kind of funny
hi manny um for switzerland i know i
played for consent for
um for spain i played for
montgomery for austria
i don't remember
for belgium i think i played for ghent
i might be wrong it's been like three
years four years
almost five years now entering 2021
whoa
yeah black might want to try something
like that but f5s would only
seriously work if the center is already
closed
if this and there's so many amazing
carlson corona on all of those big guys
games at least
around 2014 15 16 on these lines
because i remember there were so many
great games that i was learning when i
was just beginning to learn
this game this opening
so that is something that you could
seriously consider if you are
considering to
learning this opening um
no i don't think i i don't think that
this is a good idea because that doesn't
really do much you kind of you should
try and keep your bishops because
with this type of centers when
everything is possible you don't know
you might want to take over here
troy like the bishop on c5 so you
shouldn't just give up the bishop
so yeah
[Music]
yeah perry you are correct
um that is possible steve um so
it is black to move what do you think we
should do as black
why just play this knight d2 normal move
doesn't really want to do much
just normal moves oh thank you
you could try something yeah you could
potentially try moving the knight
c65 um but yeah
so generally in lopez
we don't want to rush into it especially
with this e5 pawn being weak you can't
just do this your e5 pawn will be very
punished
uh one thing that you shouldn't do oscar
is to move this knight and play f5
unless this pawn is already on d5
that's that's something that a lot of
i've done few times and
actually that does get you very
uncomfortable
if you just start moving your knight and
pushing your pawn when the center is
still
not closed you will get punished and
it's not it's not pretty
yeah even when i was playing lower rates
i had a hard time trying to
find something um b5 is the move i went
for
bishop whoops bishop b3 knight a5 bishop
c2
c5 so i got some some stuff in the
center i might want to start poking
around here a little bit
i might want to do a queen c7 get the
bishop out
so this is very lopez typical
so if you do play lopez with white or
black this is a very typical thing to do
with your bishop on e7 usually
but the bishop is also
on g7 very prime position because
imagine if you can get a b4 and open up
this
uh this bad boy that's going to be a lot
of fun
thank you thank you i don't know if
that's ben or tracy but thank you for
catching that
anyways so my opponent played knight f1
he's a grand master the ukrainian 25
60 25 70 almost so this
is he's not he's not a kid he knows what
he's doing
so i was trying my best to behave and be
very cautious of what i was doing
and i didn't want to rush it rookie
ain't has a good choice but i wasn't 100
sure where i wanted this trip
but i knew i wanted this queen to be
somewhere in the queen side
so where do you guys think this queen
should go where do you think it would
benefit us more
i don't really feel the bishop g4 i
don't really know what i want to do with
this bishop because you can always do
like a 93
and poke this bishop and i don't really
want to come back
so i'm kind of i'm going to keep my
bishop here
you could try this yes that is one of
the things
um i went for a queen c7 because it was
kind of defending e5 i could try to
do like a rook d8 um
i wasn't entirely sure what to do with
my bishop and that was one of my biggest
problems
so um in the game my opponent played
this a4
and so the idea of a4 is pretty obvious
right he wants to open up a little bit
in the king side
wants to poke a little bit try to k
sorry
queenside tries to open the rook um
i made a decision to play bishop d7 i do
think bishop b7 was a little bit smarter
to be honest
because i could start considering d5
more seriously
but i think i slightly chickened out
and i went for bishop d7
and the problem with bishop d7 is this
knight e3
as it happened in the game and it's not
like a big
problem it's not like white gets
anything out of it but it just
makes flights a little bit more
comfortable uh
in the game i just went with rookie
eight again here
what do you think can we take it should
we push it what do you think we should
do as black
i also it's kind of funny at the
flexible truth i've been reading a
little of the organic chemistry for mcat
and the easy is like this system that
you do to
like assign priorities when there is a
double bond
and that kind of um got me a little
a little ptsd nothing that serious
with organic chemistry
oh bishop c6 is interesting i kind of
think b4 would be the way to go
um nimi
no not necessarily i don't think we
should take it because if you take it
you are giving your opponent a serious
guide to go after
he is going to take it and if you take
it that's not really going to be
pleasant because you have this dark
squared bishop all of these dark squared
pawns your pawn is just like a tall pawn
your bishop is like a tall pawn
this is another weakness i don't think
we should do that you don't want to give
your opponent chances to whoop you
generally um so
here my opponents um i mean i think i
was considering before i didn't
do b4 i thought b4 would be interesting
if you take it then i take it and that
is actually pretty cool
i can think about b3s i could think
about
maybe moving this bishop a little now i
know where to go with this bishop
i could try to move the stroke a little
bit it would be more interesting
but i think i was worried that if b4
just bishop d2
and maybe then i could do like queen b7
that's something to consider because b3
is also coming up
um in the game i was a little hesitant
and i didn't do this this is i think
what i should have done
just i did a different move order i
played queen b7 first which is a very
normal move nothing wrong with it
i am still planning on pushing this pawn
um
however um i kind of gave my opponent
the chance to stop
so why to move how do you think white is
going to stop this idea of b4 b3
because let's be let's be like let's be
real if h3 i will play b4 and then i
will play b3 and your bishop is going to
get pretty ugly
so black to move sorry
white to move how can white stop you
um i'm flat oh
well uh i'm annie b4 is something to
consider
but before writes now or before
after like a takes b5 and then b4
you if you were to play b4 right away
take take in knight c6
um it's good but
knight d4 is also coming up also also
take um no i'm not going to actually do
this because you would simply have take
and then my knight is a bit misplaced
bishop can go to a3
and kind of like starts to minimize my
night's
moves maybe i would just take back
probably with
the same pawn with take
interesting bishop d2 to defend this
this is also interesting
i think b4 could have worked but
um taking first is a tiny bit sneakier
because now i take it and then you do b4
now i have a choice do i take it
or do i play knight c6 which one do you
think we should do
hmm oh hi exquisite no queen b5 wouldn't
really work
well um taking is actually very
interesting because after take knight c6
we get to the same position
and zero k attricate
black does have a little bit of an age
this is
i think this uh this line would have
been quite pleasant
for black with the queen b7 early on
right here i made a little
move choice uh inaccuracy
oops i played rookie 8 first because i
wasn't sure if what i want to do
i was thinking maybe i can still try and
push for
d5s and so i played this rookie 8
this is still perfectly fine move you
don't really have to worry about it
there's nothing
wrong with it it just kind of doesn't
exactly
go with the flow and that was a small
problem that i faced later on
because my opponent did bishop d2
preparing for this b4
and then i did my queen b7 but
now i didn't really have to do queen b7
because
the the position kind of shifted a
little
now if i do this queen b7 my opponent
can easily do this b4 the queen is
defending a1
and that's like a tiny better version of
the initial the other position that we
saw
yep this is kind of a trigger in line
but with the visual on g7
so i'm going to go back to before queen
b7 and ask you guys so black to move
what do you think we should do i agree
aristotle it was
um i wasn't completely certain exactly
what plan i wanted to do
which i think was a big mistake um if i
was playing this right now i would be
like okay so
if i'm going to play in the queen side
i'm not really going to do a d5 so i
don't really need a rook on e8 i would
have kind of eliminated your k8
but um this was this was not the last
round i think this was
one of the last rounds leading the i
think it was around seven out of nine
and i was a little nervous
to be completely honest and i was
playing higher i did i really wanted to
get my norms and
this wasn't exactly going um it wasn't
as easy
what is roy lopez um is the opening e4
e5 knight f3 knight c6 bishop's
b5 you are correct harry c4 would be
interesting
because now if you play d4 now i can do
queen b7
and starts going after this poor guy
while defending my guy and
keeping an eye on your guy so a lot of
fun stuff happening
okay so let's go back i went for queen
b7
take take b4 take take and knight comes
back
see if the bishop was on c1 like we
wanted to have it
like in the other position with my rook
on f8 i wouldn't have lost the tempo
it's not such a huge deal but it's just
like little things like this add up
together and then your opponent ends up
getting an advantage
so he played bishop to b3 going after f7
well maybe not there's exact going after
f7 just placing it in an ideal diagonal
i like that explanation better so black
to move
how are you going to come up with a plan
captain doll i see some fun emojis
what's up
that is true taking is a blender but
you see this bishop coming to b3 and
you're you might feel a little
uncomfortable so how can you
um help that bishop b6 is definitely a
candidate move
was i just trying to draw no i was
setting trap but at the same time i
wasn't going to take unnecessary risks
like here i wouldn't play something like
knight d4 or take rook takes a one
actually takes that one is not so bad
i wouldn't do unnecessary risks what is
going on here that is a very great
question
my opponent is trying to poke around and
i don't like getting poked
um that might be an interesting idea to
try and rearrange the knight a little
but
right now something like knight g5 might
bother me
so i decided to just play h6 it's not a
bad move but it's also not like the best
move i do think
that the best move here would have
probably just been
bishop v6 if you take it i simply take
it back with the pawn
that is what i was unsure about i was
not sure about this pawn structure
and that is why i didn't actually go
into this line but this one
uh at this point but this pawn structure
is actually perfectly fine
nothing wrong with it it's not exactly
um
everybody's dream like you don't sit at
night in your bed and look in the
ceiling i'm like oh my god i really want
that pawn structure
but it does not it is a very doable pawn
structure nothing really wrong with it
um i was just a little
not it didn't feel right i could have
uh i know taking here was would not
really be
as why is because now take
take and then knight d5 is coming up
because you can't take it
and the also just knight c7 so you can't
really do rook e8 this knight d5 would
really
punish you
yeah i'm not the biggest fan of this
line
so i just was like okay you want my f7
pawn ain't gonna happen i just played h6
um nice nice reference alexander you got
my
you got my joke yeah so my opponent also
played h3 i really don't know why i
guess just
why not and
so in the game what do you think we
should do
you can you can see that opponent is
also
uh not in a rush you can see that none
of you guys none of none white or black
actually has like a super plan and it's
a super strategy game
so how are you going to play
thank you james pratt i think so too i'm
kidding
sure peachy thinks so too
why is queen wrong on b3 um i don't
think queen is wrong on b3
but
um i do
like this idea of having this knight on
e6 but at the same time my knight on c6
is something that he doesn't have
so this light could be could become a
little more interesting
just where it is then on e6
[Music]
so what about doubling up because
another thing that i have
is the queen on b7 and the rooks could
just double up when my opponent can't
so why shouldn't we use that
yeah let's take the a file oh thank you
rahul
yep let's go up for k6
now to be fair my opponent should have
used this time and played knight d5
if i take it knight bishop takes and try
to poke around and make some pens and
needles and stuff like that
and that is something that my opponent
could have done but he didn't
and he simply played bishop c3
now i brought my other rack
i could have taken and then played
bishop e6 this is something that i
really should do at some point
and i remember if i remember correctly i
did but not the next few moves i mean
nuts
right away right away i wanted to take
this file
which doesn't really do much because
this bishops are really protecting
everything on it
so my opponents played queen b1 i
can't really think why this queen b1
mattered i'm assuming maybe clean wants
to go to b2
and just try to do something here
so now black to move what do you think
we should do
there are few holes that we could try to
poke
and this is a little scary my cat has
been sleeping up there for the last
three hours and then he was also
sleeping next to me in bed for about
most of the morning slash afternoon too
he did have a stressful day on saturday
tuesday get over it
i'm maddie i agree he needs to rest
he can come rest right next to me so i
can pet him while he rests
ah nobody's actually saying that exact
move so
one thing is this this hole to be poked
we could just go
do this that's one thing but uh the idea
of
whoa not not that the idea of knight h5
it
makes me a slightly uncertain of
because of this knight d5 and then we
would do bishop e6
and then try to take it and denied f4
that's um
doesn't really feel as happy
so i just went for bishop v6 in the game
finally
i was ready that when you take take
and you do this queen b3 i thought i was
a little happy
because um i liked the idea of you
lost the tempo to get here instead of
just doing queen b3
so i kind of like that idea i thought it
was like i was winning something from
you i was like stealing the tempo
so i like that um i went queen e7
it's perfectly normal queen d7 was also
doable
uh he did rook c1 going after this
knight now
black to move again what do you think we
should do keep in mind this is a very
strategic move
and i am i am black i am playing higher
rated opponents
and i'm trying to hold my ground while
setting mini traps for him
disc free um
oh books well it really depends on how
much time
you have because if you have enough time
and if you if you are that dedicated
everything is easier with a private
trainer but if you don't and you want to
do it on your own i would recommend
having some friends that you can
exchange information and play with
that's another thing um chess.com
montliches both
do have very great material to just try
to get you
started i don't know your age but
i'm i've become a big fan of chess kits
they actually
do have very very nice videos
uh for beginners that kind of goes
through everything you need to know
how the pieces move how that's like
super beginner it also has like more
tactics how to think about tactics
it's very organized so i recommend that
for any beginner regardless of their age
it is called chess kids but it does have
very very basic videos
anyways um i don't think that this
knight is in
any serious danger at the moment but you
could
simply try to just maneuver around a
little i think uh knight dash 5
i'm not the biggest fan it is this
doable but
i'm not the biggest fan i went for
knight d7 in the game i wanted to go up
here
and he did bishop d2 stopping my knight
b6
i just at this point i was like you know
what
we're we're doing this tango i want to
do something you blocking i want to do
i do you want to do something i block it
let's just do this king h7
don't have to worry about any kind of
checks i'm my king is also protecting my
pawns my king is safe let's keep it
there
i went for dads and he did knight c2
now what do you think we should do can
we can we continue with this
idea should we move this night somewhere
else
should we do anything what do you think
we should do
actually knight of six is is a very good
move i think it's actually the best move
you realize your nice job is down there
you go back
d5 doesn't really work there are two
attackers only one defender
careful but i assume the idea of knight
f6 is to play d5
oh also i see the number of viewers are
going up lovely
should make tracy happy
um you could actually probably you could
try to do something like this but the
problem is
knight a3 and those that started
attacking this pawn
so that is why you actually need to move
this guy so you could come queen b7 and
defend your pawn when there is a knight
a3
so let's say you applied knight f6
knight a3
queen b7 that's something you could play
because um he can't really eat your pawn
now
loses the knight but you have to be
careful because
as black these are your weaknesses so
you should be careful
with these pawns
item knight b6 again problem is knight
a3 and your
your pawn falls
so i played knight f8 knight fight was
not
it was it was the second best move the
best move was knight f6
i put i went mighty fade yep harry
knight f8
um and he played h4 which i don't
fully understand i wasn't really
planning on queen i7
but i mean i got the chance after hr i
was like yep let's go queen a7 we are
gonna start
moving around this truck and
i do think that bishop e3 was the best
one so congratulations
you saw this move and the grandmaster
didn't i'm talking about my opponent i
see every move
uh h4 queen a7 trying to poke around
with the rook a little
and now he went g3 and i was just like
huh
i didn't really understand what my
opponent was trying to do
but the one thing i knew i should do is
well i don't really like having hanging
stuff
so this knight could be hanging so let's
just go queen a8 we're defending the
night i like having my stuff defended
um he played bishop c3
and i finally did rook a2 there is no
serious threat with the rook here
but it just looks good i also might do
queen a4
yeah i manny exactly you shouldn't just
follow the same plan that is one of the
big differences
between like a um 20
300 and 2500 is that they only like they
they have to be able to make that
flexibility
to be flexible to make that small change
um so i had some ideas so what do you
think is the best move for white
we were almost halfway through with the
game actually never mind my
bad almost halfway yeah
oh thank you
yep or k1 you guys are correct uh d4 is
another idea that
white could have had just try and go for
d4 and
try to open up a little bit but i would
probably still do this queen a4
because if you take it now that's gonna
be kind of cool now i could take it with
the pawn
try and poke around a little here
i kind of like this idea but my
opponents went through k1
i have to take take and
i was a little confused because i
thought okay you might want to do some
stuff here
so let's try to stop you so i went for
bishop f6
my idea was simply to uh if you play
something like h5 i could take it and
then like do knight g6
and h4 i just like the idea of having my
bishop against your knight
so um after bishop f6
he played bishop b2 i'm assuming bishop
b2 was just
a simple move to free the knights the
one thing that i would strongly
recommend to everybody
is generally as gen as a general rule
try to
always have your um pieces protected
with something don't
leave dropping pieces only hanging
pieces because
those are going to be the tactical um
the things that are going to be eaten
tactically or at least maneuvered on or
abused and used and all the stuff that
you don't want to have
so you shouldn't try your best to not
um to not allow
to not leave any of your pieces hanging
and that's one thing that you do
very nicely didn't leave any hanging
pieces
this position is very equal we both have
equal chances
we're both trying to just find the
better moves and just um
hang in there basically i don't think
anybody is actually better at this
position
white does seem to have a small
very small advantage but trying to
convert
trying to convert that is going to be
very hard um so my phone just went for
bishop b2
just king g7 i am keeping my
stuff all protected not leaving any man
behind
any soldier behind um bishop c1
trying to poke around a little now black
to move what do you think we should do
uh the move that i the move that i did
looked good practically but it didn't
i slightly regretted it in the game
exquisite i see you've been trying to do
d5 the problem with d5
is that if white doesn't take your pawn
on d5 is extremely misplaced because you
can't take on e4 because your e5 and e6
will be very weak
you can't push on d4 because again your
e5 and e6 will be very weak
so d5 you should only play d5 when white
absolutely has to take it
no we're done moving the king
i mean you could play king h7 but it
doesn't really do anything for you
[Music]
oh um guys we're not accepting
challenges
also queen a4 um
queen a4 possible
white would simply do something like
queen c3 maybe
that's something to keep in mind i don't
really um it doesn't really
feel like there is much to it you would
probably just come back
uh in the game what do you guys think
about knight d4
i manny i don't think uh this command of
iron rosen works here unless he is going
to pop up magically
we should have a commander gmp
um so the idea of knight d4 might be
interesting
that is actually what i played and it
felt i mean it looks good
there's nothing like seriously wrong
with it but at the same time i didn't
really feel like it was the best way to
go
my opponent simply took take and played
quincy too
he kind of won this line and i didn't
really like it
i played queen v7 to stop you from
entering
any of it so i kind of like that idea
about it
but now white actually did gain a tiny
bit more advantage so
why to move what can you do
that you couldn't do a few moves ago
and my opponent actually missed this i
was so scared of this move
nope think a little more
yes yeah sierra slope queen d2 and it
would make it uncomfortable it's not
like white is winning but it was
definitely going to make
my life more miserable
um so
yeah if you mean you're not really going
to go for this check at the moment
but you are um but this is going to be a
little bit more weakness
now you can again try to go from the
other side keep more
pressure try to bring more stuff to just
put more pressure so that's why you
should
do you should like white should have
done this and i should have gone for
this
idea um if white would play this
i actually uh it's a very uncomfortable
position i
sincerely don't know what i would have
done um
so i uh yeah
yeah i mean there's nothing else to do
besides s5 so queen d2
was white's chance to actually win this
game and he missed it the grand master
so it is very possible to like
not just because you are you're
higher rated and your grandmaster
doesn't mean that you
are going to find everything so that's
one thing to keep in mind when the lower
rated players play with the higher rated
opponent
you don't have to be scared of him you
should just try to
eliminate all possible plans and i
missed this i missed it
so he just went king g2 and now i was
like okay
i gotta be careful now this is happening
so let's do king h7 so if you go queen
d2 i have bishop g7
uh in the game he played bishop d bishop
b2 and i1 just went to e5
all right so this bond is fixed this
pawn is defending it this guy is
defending that guy
and now i could just try to bring up the
knight
maybe i can try to go to a4 that looks
cute
um in the game he went queen b3
uh stopping my knight ideas and i went
back king g7
there is no more attack on h6 so i can
he went back bishop c1 i'm assuming he
also realized that potentially this was
kind of fun i went back
nope i'm going back i'm gonna defend it
and i just simply wasted a few moves
i was also trying to reach move forward
yet
so i could get my extra time and i was
just waiting
to see what he wants to do as soon as i
realized okay
so he's not exactly going for f4
that gave me another idea now i can go
queen to c8 and start
looking into this maybe i can go queen
c3
in the game he rightfully plays bishop
d2
stopping this now black to move
what do you think we should do
oh my minor pieces are not that sad oh
it's 5am in iran yeah that makes sense
my mom is asleep
well yarista we're not exactly trying to
break through we're just trying to
improve the pieces
and uh that's kind of
what we're going for in this position
oh 2 am in bellshop it is pretty late
so glad you guys are still watching me
though
yeah let's get the nights out whoops
yeah let's get the knight out you stop
my queen c396
um yeah the idea of g5 is also possible
but knight e6 kind of makes more sense
and i'm just slowly slowly bringing up
my pieces
uh he played queen a2 i just went h5
again to be fair g5 was the way to go
because g5 h5 and then i could have
tried
to um maybe bring up the queen a little
maybe just try and maneuver the bishop
around um
i this would have been a little bit more
um doable with g5
but i was scared of my f5 square and
this knight somehow getting to
it but it's going to be very very
hard to do that like you would have to
make some seriously
kill or maneuver just try to get here my
head hurts just looking at it
um i played h5 h5
kind of gave this g5 square to my
opponent
and it wasn't the most accurate way
and he immediately spotted it here was
like okay i got the g
square let's go back boys but it's not
like a serious uh it's not a huge
advantage it's just like a tiny bit
but it's like a tiny bit of hope
psychologically and
chassis oh gmp she is awake grooming
himself
d7 knight f3 going after g5
and i went knight c7 i kind of gave up
on g5
this wasn't exactly um as ideal as
possible but i really wanted to try to
get to these squares
or try to do d5 that was my idea
um he just went yeah i should have just
went for knight d8
and just tried to keep it super cool but
i i
maybe knight f7 hold that square i went
to knight c7 and i got queen i7 so now
like to move what to do ah thank you
nimi that is very nice of you
good night or good morning for you i
literally
it is pretty late there
ah bishop d8 um not exactly
you gotta start using this king i went
king f7 kind of proud of my king f7
um because this king i mean you gotta
use it
you are yeah you shouldn't self pin
exactly thank you
thank you everybody so bishop g5 and
i was like yep i gotta take that i can't
exactly play king asylum so take
take and now king e7 my self pin is
resolved
and queen b8 eh
my opponents made a mistake queen b7 was
a little bit better
but to top that the other mistake
was um
i think bishop g5 was a little bit
premature maybe bishop h6
just to hold holds the um advantage a
little bit
but anyways i this is the position that
we ended up in
now black to move what should we do
ah this is tea not coffee i i try not to
have
more than one cup of coffee per day
a middle eastern i love tea
and maybe 96 no you should be careful
because
96 is possible but queen g8 is very
scary
so if you do knight a6 you have to know
what to do after queen g8
take um take well not that
take it's a little bit scary i wouldn't
exactly want to end in this position
um these are some seriously strong pawns
and this is
somewhat of a sad king i didn't want to
risk it
maybe somebody else would but i didn't i
wanted to save onside i wanted queen d8
if you take it oh great i'll take it
back and now i can't eat that guy
uh he was smart he played queen b6
not taking it queen d7 just waiting if
you'd repeat
awesome if not my queen is there
stopping all these ideas i can try to
move my knight a little
um he played queen king h2 actually
don't really know why i just went to
queen c8 trying to improve a little bit
he could have done queen c6 which he did
uh trying to still self pin me but again
queen d7 so i was trying to get somewhat
of a perpetual here
but um it wasn't the right time and he
wasn't really having it
he was still fighting because he had the
more active knights more active queen
so he was still fighting 96
and he took here i took with king which
was fine
but this started to bother me a little
because now i have to move my queen in
yeah i'm attacking
but this is a little uncomfortable so
black to move what do you think we
should do
should you hold the position with just
moving the king around or should you
actually open up
yep you should hold yeah you should play
this like king d7
simple hold just keep moving the king
around
your queen is amazing this king can't
move you're great don't don't mess it up
if that's not that's all i should have
done just put the king to d7 and chill
but i don't i can't chill all the time
so i played d5
d5 was a mistake because queen c1 would
have punished me
because now you're getting queen c6 you
want to take over here
your queen is activated uh in the game
he simply took
i took back and went queen h8 now this
coin is beginning to be a little pokey
pokey and i'm in series sometime trouble
so i played queen f5 which was a bad
move
i saw a pawn i wanted to go eat it but
it was bad
i should have just played queen d7 keep
my cool
don't give up any pawns i thought queen
g8 losing this pawn would be um
inevitable but i was wrong about that my
queen should have just stayed on like
this
sixth string and just protected the king
i
didn't do that i want i thought i could
play aggressively and i played queen f5
it was a mistake
now what do you think white can do to
punish me
whoops
i agree exquisite it does feel pretty
scary
yeah luke you're right queen i8
check you gotta move the king another
check you gotta move the king and it's
here
tada now um
i realized that we were both
in serious serious time trouble and
i realized that i have to bluff my way
out of this
otherwise i've just lost the pawn my
opponent is feeling pretty awesome right
now he just ate my pawn
and i i will lose this game it's already
plus two for my opponent anyways
and this is an easy end game to win so i
was like okay so
i have a choice either i'm gonna bluff
my way out of it or i'm gonna get busted
and
uh have to have some ice cream after the
game so i played e4 yes
e4 is actually a losing move
not because of the move e4 because not
because of the queen end game because of
the opponent game because you can take
take and you have this outside past pawn
and all you have to do is just play king
f1 man you're winning
or you can even take this
take and then king f1 i can't really do
much
because also g4 is happening and you
have these two past pawns
so that is why we should always know our
opponent game
because at almost 2600 didn't feel
comfortable in his
opponent game skills because if he did
you don't really need to calculate you
should be like okay
e4 is weird i can just take it and i
have this pass pawn
and i can also create this past pawn huh
that's a weird move and that should be
there shouldn't be much calculation
there should be just like
opponent games past pawns two of them
whoops let's go and my bluff actually
worked after e4 he did not take it
she played queen c4 and now i'm back in
the game
um after queen c4 i just played king b7
he took
i took king moved and now i also have a
passport
queen end games you need to have past
pawns like you don't have past ones
you should you should create past pawns
i went king v6
and i was actually beginning to
get a little too excited and
um i was throwing in some checks and now
actually if you were to take it while i
win
that is we all can agree on that but
here my opponent played queen c6 now
black to move what to do should we go
should we take this pawn
uh is this a winning end game for black
is this a losing end game
is the draw what is it
yep exquisite
i'm glad you like this gears too
what do you think guys should we take
that
why not we can take the play king b6 eat
the pawn
what's wrong with that
my king is close enough you take taking
b6 i pick up your pawn what's wrong with
it
we should take it yeah
take take king b6 in the game he went
king f3
take take king c5 you're protecting your
pawn
but this is also a draw because
you just kind of wait around and you
just kind of
wait around and here we agreed to a draw
because my king is right on the on time
i could take
take and just bring my king and it's
right on time you have three moves i
have three moves to get here
so yeah it was a draw and
i'm very glad that i found this and i
wasn't scared of my pawn and game skills
and the funny part was that when i
actually played this
e4 i knew that it is a um
my e4 here i know i was losing
it was just a matter of bluffing and i'm
very proud that i did that
so with that
that is one of my favorite games that i
actually got away
so i hope you guys enjoy it um that is
kind of all the time that we have for
tonight
and this is my official last stream for
2020 and i said that
i've said that before but this is this
time is true
because also there's only two more days
left on the calendar
and i will see you guys next tuesday
hope you have a great end of your year
uh
have a lot of cake and champagne and
i will see you tuesday have a great rest
of your year
see you in 2020